by show of hands who thinks we're a
better couple than jim and pam
hey hey i got you one oh wow thank you
yeah i'm just gonna grab some chips you
want some no thanks uh we're still
having lunch today right
i guess
how dare you
hey toby
what's this huh i just want to remind
everyone about the company rules
involving pda
or public displays of affection yes uh
some people in the office have
complained oh not some other people
engaging in pda and you know just want
to remind it's not appropriate to to do
that this is about me and jan in my
office because i will have you know that
that was consensual what we did
has nothing to do with you or anyone
here i don't think
anyone heard anything we were very
discreet and and i most people had left
by that point so i don't i don't think
it's any of your business so what i
think you should do is roll up the memo
real tight okay hey look the memo is not
about you for the record i have never
been involved with anyone at work in any
capacity all right everyone look you
all right the complaint was about jim
and pam so
no way what you guys are together
um
[Music]
yep
yes we are wow
wow
awesome
to the two of you yes
yes toby was this your fun little way of
congratulating us
yes okay mind is exploding get over here
come on
come here
okay
okay stand up
okay here we go
everyone this is a day
that will live in infamy
because today
is the day
that jim and pam
become one actually i've been dating for
a couple months i
love you guys so much
no no no pam let him ring
let the
bells of dunder mifflin chime out your
love
because
this is really good this is really good
my heart
soars
with the eagle's nest
i don't see it i think they both could
do better
it's not a surprise to me
pam is the office mattress
oh
wow look at those how nice for you
up there front and center beautiful i
think they would look better right here
they're very pretty and i wouldn't want
them to fall
i swore i wouldn't tell anybody this but
in the interest of
revealing secrets
oh my god it's gonna make your brain
explode um dwight
and angela
dating
have been for six months no i swear to
god
oh this is great i was actually gonna
wait and tell you on your birthday but
this is much more fun
no they have been dating for like two
years
since before your barbecue
wait
what
you knew
you didn't say anything you didn't say
anything to me
fair enough
wow we should have started dating like a
long time ago
oh
sorry i didn't know you guys were in
here i don't know we're just sitting
here i couldn't see your hands
um
hey pam by the way
it's great that you're dating
but when a new client calls
you just have to randomly assign them to
a salesperson
you can't base who gets new clients on
who you're sleeping with that week
okay okay
okay
okay
and
that is why we waited so long to tell
people
i'm not a romantic
actually i think i am and
i have a little bit of experience in
office romance oh really yeah like with
who
we've been through this
pam yes we are still dating and guess
what i took it slow
yeah you took it too slow well we're
really happy oh thank you hank you are a
lifesaver hank
i appreciate it all right so hank is
going to come down here he's going to
let us all out he said it should be just
under an hour so
we did it we should all make sure to
give him a big tip this christmas sorry
guys but i don't think i chipped in for
last year's
yeah neither did i yeah jim was supposed
to collect it
yep way to go man no he's never gonna
come by show of hands who thinks we're a
better couple than jim and pam
phyllis
well i should go
all right i'll tell everybody here that
you say hi no don't i'm mad at them why
would happen not one of them called to
congratulate me on our engagement
ah
that they might be off the hook for
because i didn't tell them what why not
i just didn't you know
on a deal come on it won't be that bad
okay
you know what
here we go
uh everybody just wanted to make an
announcement
pam and i are engaged hi
everyone i thought you were already
engaged nope that was roy she was
engaged to roy
thank you angela i got a gift for pam
and roy do i have to get another one
yes a little close to my engagement
there tuna what's your game here to get
married
she's not a virgin you know
wow
hey toby
hey
youtube hey
so now that we are dating
uh we just wanted to know if we had to
sign one of those we're dating things
for the company
oh well you know those were only for
you know relationships
so
if it's just a casual thing there's no
need really
oh well i don't want to speak for jim
but
it's like pretty official
uh-huh
sorry so do we need to
sign one or
let's just wait and see what happens
yeah
what
let's just wait
oh okay okay great
all right something's come up i gotta go
no no she'll wake up no i have something
to do i know what you have to do please
stay with cece
dwight
i've always considered us to be very
good friends great friends
remember your concussion
i do
but you married my worst enemy well i
think enemy's a strong word because i
think we have a really charming back and
forth
so it plays on the infinity thing
without being obvious yeah you know
um i'd love to do like a color version
just bring a little color i like it a
lot
it's clear and subtle at the same time
it's really good you have a real talent
for this stuff
thanks i'd love to talk to you about it
more
that'd be great do you want to go out to
dinner tonight
oh is it why something nice no
what
um i just
i just wanted him dinner
i'm uh i'm i'm dating jim
you're kidding
we're together
that's
great i
that's awesome
yeah um great
so let me uh yeah let me look at these
okay great
great
hey kelly
oh so jealous of your boobs
thank you
um listen i just wanted to confirm that
you're not coming to the wedding which
is totally understandable and more than
fine
is ryan going
i don't know he has an rsvp yet we
invited everyone in the office to our
wedding even though we realized most
people wouldn't be able to make the
drive to niagara falls
which is why we're having it in niagara
falls
then michael told everyone they could
have friday and monday off if they came
so now people have to decide if they
want to come to our wedding
or have to work
here's the deal i really want to go but
i'm not gonna go if ryan doesn't go
because it's kind of a waste of time
that came out wrong it would be awesome
if you could try to get him to go
because i'd really like to be there to
support jim
well this is intimate we just had to add
a few more tables we weren't expecting
this many people you don't know them all
nope and we're gonna need a loaves and
fishes kind of miracle to feed them all
jesus is not your caterer
but he should be your gator cause you're
a little angel why didn't your parents
get you a caterer
they don't think honestly
jim gives me the creeps
you